Disney's live-action remake of one of
their most treasured animations Beauty
and the Beast must have been a
formidable challenge for the film makers
as they had to decide how to reimagine
iconic characters scene songs and
locations from the 1991 oscar-winning
movie yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's
Jan here and in my last video I revealed
some incredible facts you probably
didn't know about Disney's animated
classic but now in this video I want to
let you in on some amazing secrets and
facts about the making of the new
live-action Beauty and the Beast costume
designer Jacqueline Duran tested lots of
different shades of yellow on camera
before choosing the final color for
Belles ballgown once that was decided
the dress took a hundred and eighty feet
of satin organza three thousand feet of
thread over two thousand swarovski
crystals and more than 12,000 hours to
make and goldleaf filigree was also
printed on the top two layers of the
gown in a design which matched the
ballroom floor as for the dress that
Belle was right at the end of the movie
the print for that was actually based on
an original eighteenth-century apron
that the film's costume designer bought
during her student days the household
objects like Lumiere Cogsworth and mrs.
Potts were brought to life using a
time-consuming mix of computer-generated
effects during post-production and solid
models during on set filming for example
a real version of the Wardrobe garderobe
was built and raked with pulleys and
various devices so she could move on
sense but when we see garderobe dress
Belle that was created thanks to the
magic of visual effects in
post-production
as for Lumiere the filmmakers wanted to
incorporate actor Ewan McGregor's
personality into the singing candelabra
so they used performance capture
technology to film McGregor moving and
dancing how he thought
Lumiere would also before filming began
McGregor and the other actors who played
the enchanted characters recorded that
dialogue so it could be used as a guide
for the cast and crew during the actual
shoot so when Dan Stevens was filming a
scene with Lumiere for instance he was
acting opposite an LED light on a stick
and hearing you McGregor's pre-recorded
voice then during post-production
McGregor and his fellow enchanted
character actors recorded their dialogue
again so it matched the tone of what was
happening on-screen apparently the most
difficult object to design according to
director Bill Condon was mrs. Potts
although the animated version of the
character has a spa
out for a nose Condon told The Hollywood
Reporter that when they tried that for
the live-action version she ended up
looking like a pig and he added that
there was no way to make that spout nose
appealing in three dimensions when you
see the servants in their human form do
look out for how their costumes and
hairstyles mirror their appearance as
enchanted objects for example the
buttons on cogs worse human costume have
Roman numerals on them just like his
clock face and the design on Kong's
worse waistcoat and epaulets also echoes
the pattern we see on him when he's a
clock and if you look at his hairstyle
you'll notice that it's inspired by the
shape of [ __ ] worth the clocks head
bringing to life the Busby Berkeley
style song-and-dance number be our guest
was a massive challenge that took the
film's crew six months to prepare 1
months to film and more than 12 months
to finish when I spoke to director Bill
Condon recently he said that initially
they did consider creating the beast
using prosthetic makeup but because that
wouldn't have allowed a subtle facial
performance to come through properly
they didn't pursue that option too long
before deciding to go high-tech
and combine physical and facial
performance capture to bring the beast
to life the physical performance capture
part involved Stephens acting alongside
fellow cast members on practical sets
which was anything but easy as he had to
wear 10 inch metal stilts as well as a
prosthetics muscle suit that weighed 18
kilograms and a grey lycra bodysuit
covered in visual effects markers and
beneath all that Stevens also wore a
special cooling vest which the crew
plugged in between takes to help
regulate his temperature the second part
of playing the Beast took place later
and began with Dan Stephens face being
covered in phosphorescent makeup which
looks blue in ultraviolet light with his
special makeup on Stephens then acted
out all his scenes again but this time
he did so from just the neck up sitting
alone in a booth surrounded by cameras
to capture his facial performance which
the movie's VFX teams used to give life
to the beasts face on the big screen
Bell's hometown of veal nerve was built
on a huge back lot at Shepperton studios
and was the movie's bigger set measuring
over 28,000 square feet and that size
was certainly necessary for the film's
first musical number which features over
150 extras hundreds of animals 28 wagons
and a myriad of highly detailed props
and set decorator
and when it came to designing the
fictional towns look the movies
production designer took inspiration
from a village in the South of France
called conch the film story is set in
mid 18th century France so for the look
of the beasts castles the art department
was heavily influenced by the very
ornate Rococo style popular during that
period and which included lots of
intricate designs curved shapes plant
motifs and gold as for the castles
ballroom that features a 12,000 square
foot faux marble floor with a pattern
that was actually inspired by the
ceiling design in a Benedictine
monastery in Bavaria Germany and the
ballrooms 10 huge chandeliers are based
on ones from the Palace of Versailles in
France the set for the enchanted forest
around the castle features about 20,000
icicles a frozen lake real trees and a
pair of 29 foot high ice gates it was
built on Shepperton Studios biggest
stage which measures over nine and a
half thousand square feet and it took
the movies crew 15 weeks to make it
before filming began director Bill
Condon worked one to one with each his
actors to fine-tune their characters
personalities and backstories after that
the cast did a table read of the full
script and they even performed some of
the musical numbers in full giving the
read-through the feel of a live concert
for the movies crew by the way that
musical read-through took place on the
15th of April 2015 which coincidentally
was also the birthday of Emma Watson who
plays Belle Luke Evans who plays Gaston
Emma Thompson who plays mrs. Potts and
Nathan Mack who plays chip now have you
seen Beauty and the Beast yet and do you
like how it's been adapted and were
there any scenes costumes or songs that
you've specially enjoyed in the new
movie I'd love to hear your thoughts in
the comments below and if you enjoyed
this video a thumbs up is really
appreciated and I've got more Beauty in
the Beast videos on the way including a
chance to win this awesome Disney
hardback book so do subscribe and turn
on your notifications so you don't miss
my next beauty in the Beast video and in
the meantime check out these other
videos you might like by tapping or
clicking the screen here thanks for
watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers